can you talk about what is the idea of
secession what are the odds that it
might happen
what does it mean for the united states
in some way for different states to
secede sure america has been one country
with several cultures since the
beginning
um there's absolutely no reason for
someone this
goes back to the anarchist idea if you
despise donald trump which is your
prerogative
if you think joe biden is a clown which
is your prerogative
there's absolutely no reason for you to
be governed
by someone you disapprove of this is an
incoherent nonsensical concept
the only reason we even take it as a
hypothesis is that we're trained to the
contrary since kindergarten
um a secession i don't know along what
lines
but increasingly it's becoming harder
and harder
for people to have conversations i think
social media and this is
something people despise social media
for i think this is something that
social media has done well which i'm
advocating for
is it tends to kind of run through
ideas through like an evolutionary
process and drive them to the logical
inclusion
uh so it's very hard to be a moderate
online because there's gonna be people
it you know pushing through your ideas
through several cycles and then you're
gonna end up at some kind of more pure
or if you wanna dislike it extreme
perspective
having these different pockets
it's not really governable because
people fundamentally have different
world views
so i don't know what this session would
look like i think the number
is really uh increasing an exponential
rate
um i do not the number of supporters
supporters
i think the claim that this can only be
accomplished through violence is
false it's a lie uh just like any
divorce doesn't have to involve beating
your ex-husband or ex-wife
so and i i i'm very much looking forward
to this becoming a
reality far quicker than i ever expected
well do you think there's a value of um
competing world views being
forced to be in the same
yes so within a context so
we can agree if group one
thinks a b and c are the fundamental
aspects of the world view
and argue within that and world group
two thinks d e and f
and argue within that so you're going to
have a lot of argument within those
space but if there's
fundamental differences in world view
there's
no reason to be especially when each
views the other is completely incoherent
and unreasonable do you think
there's a line of fundamentally
different
world views that uh
along which a secession will happen in
the united states
is there something that emerges to you
as a set of ideas that
are like um
what do you call that like you can't
come to you can't come to an agreement
over
i yeah i think that's already happening
like with the masks
um i think there's just two fundamental
perspective and each one
thinks the other is insane and
also deadly and destructive and i don't
see how there's any
um discourse on this topic so on the
left
i wouldn't say it's left versus right i
think it's people who are pro-risk
versus people who are risk-averse
yeah so risk-averse and then there's
like a uh
a hope for the comfort of the
sort of uh centralized science
giving the the truth and then everybody
must follow the truth right
of the proper way to behave and then
there's uh on the other side
a distrust of any kind of centralized
institutions
of anybody who might uh
use uh like control to try to gain
greater and greater power and masks are
simple of that
and even if masks are or are
effective way of uh of stopping the
virus which is really unfortunate to me
as a from a perspective
i happen to be on a survey paper about
masks like people don't seem to care
about the data or the so on correct
this is this has become just a nice
point on which to then highlight the
difference between
uh the two the two sides yeah that's
really interesting i mean
i it it sounds kind of on the face
kind of ridiculous that the secession
would occur over a mask it wouldn't
but i'm saying this is an example of
something where there's a clean break
yes
um and and risk averse versus you know
uh
someone who's risk seeking these are
just two fundamentally different
perspectives do you want
have an nhs or do you have one of a
market-based healthcare system
like you can make very valid arguments
for both there's no reason for everyone
to be under one but you
you think that's not something that's
that you think that's irreconcilable
if that's the word yeah uh that
that's not in the space of ideas that
you can have in the same room together
and they fight at each other and
ultimately make progress like they
that secession is the more effective way
to proceed
forward yes well
uh do you see a possible world with
knows the answer
meaning i know you say yes because you
kind of
lean on the side of freedom and
anarchism yes
like you make you want to make let me
make an argument in terms of divorce
which is in your
world view or your intuition is you want
to make
secession as frictionless as possible
like of course along all lines not just
like states or whatever just like
absolutely you want to choose you want
to be free yeah
and peaceful let me make my
authoritarian
in terms of relationships like when
[ __ ] goes wrong in a relationship about
your language
okay there's only a place for one stall
at this table
okay okay i'll get to the linen no
you get to be like merkel as our
previous discussion with putin
okay don't let me unleash the hounds
uh it you know you want to work through
some of the troubles
before you get divorced like you want to
do the work and relationship sometimes
like
it goes up and down it's been 200 plus
years
it's uh it's done but in the listen
okay so it's not a one-night stand but
you know look at trump
this i don't see the middle ground he's
either a complete calamity buffoon
or he's been the first great president
we've had in like
many many years so you think that
there's something
different now than it was 20 years ago
yes social media and access to
information
and the division will only increase you
think oh yes so trump is not
an accident of history so they thought
trump was the river but he was the dam
trump was the dam they thought he was
the river
so that analogy trump
being gone makes things worse yes for
that perspective because now things are
really going to hit the fan
so what are the odds of secession
i don't know and my desperate hope is
that it's peaceful
but i think the number of people who are
becoming very comfortable with the
violence
is making me very unsettled well i see
words as violence and your twitter
it's like hiroshima that's a million
uh sometimes i curl up in the corner
crying after i check your twitter feed
so but you
in uh in all seriousness you um you
think it's possible to do non-violence
session it took a check of slovakia look
at brexit
brexit was the secession
right right so you can have uh civil war
did not need to be fought
that would have been an unviolent
secession and and if you worry about
slavery you could have bought off all
the slaves import them to the north
it still would have been cheaper and
less loss of life and probably better
for race relations
yeah i don't know enough history to to
wonder about like how the civil war
could have been avoided
well that's how is uh well
conversation so like no no if they want
to secede
say look here's what we're going to do
we're going to let you secede
but you have to end up slave you have to
end slavery they succeeded because of
slavery here's the other thing there's
like this con
some circles of conservatism have this
myth that oh it wasn't about slavers
about states rights
well if you go back every state when
they seceded released the press release
and they said explicitly we're doing
this because of slavery so that is an
abomination that needs to be taken care
of
but the way the other countries have you
know ended slavery peacefully
one of the ways to do it is pay them by
all
and we end up doing this after war i
think the south people got um
reparations the slave owners it was just
insane bring them north
you want to go to canada whatever and
you agree and that's our peace treaty
because the people who died weren't the
slave owners it was white trash
and it was that's who always and i hate
that's the term i can't think of a
better one but that's who always ends up
fighting these wars often
disproportionately it's poor people and
uneducated people
yeah and i don't i don't i did not
regard them as cannon fodder i think
it's horrible
so what would it look like there would
be two founding documents
yeah they had they had their
constitution actually i don't know the
history
yeah they had a constitution but it was
much more decentralized
if secession doesn't happen yeah
you said that donald trump was the dam
not the river yeah that that sounds like
walt whitman or something you should
it's poetry okay are you flirting with
me
i don't uh you know us we don't we don't
flirt we just
go to town club and drag you to the it's
just the hammer
we hammer in stickle and you don't want
to know about the sickle it's not a good
cobb back cob it's
that cup first yeah what do you think
2024 looks like
uh in terms of the candidates and it's
going to be kamal harris
as the democratic candidate uh i'm
really looking forward to ted cruz
versus mike pence
because they're both very good at debate
um that would be interesting to see how
they differentiate themselves but
honestly i don't i mean things are going
to get really ugly really soon what
about donald trump coming back
he's not going to do it um so things
in my opinion i think things are going
to be really really crazy in 2021
and talking about the damn being gone
like 2021 so this year
coming up oh yeah it's going to be
complete it's going to be complete
mayhem
what do you think like prediction-wise
and this is empirical
what do you think donald trump's twitter
feed looks like in 2021 like if we're at
the end of 2021 we'll look back
and see like what was the you know
obama gate exclamation points or we won
he is going to be for the first time in
history
holding the republican party accountable
to the the base
we've never had that happen before i i
think he's going to be holding their
feet to the fire
radicalizing them and given that they
have
the senate where it's going to be 50 50.
the democrats have a three-seat majority
in the house
this is not a governing coalition for
either um it's going to be complete
mayhem
what does that actually look like it's
like what are the key values do you
think
that he's he's going to try to push um i
think it's just going to be very
contrarian
it's he's going to be holding them
accountable in terms of budgeting even
though he
never did that as president i think in
terms of some kind of nominations
here's the thing this is the first time
since um
uh like nixon uh
50 years and things weren't as
politicized then where an incoming
president doesn't have control of the
senate
the senate has the vote over cabinet
positions
i do not see a possibility of them not
trying to pick a fight
on one or two of these nominations and
that's gonna
and especially as a revenge for
kavanaugh this is going to get very
bloody very quickly and i think mitch
mcconnell
there's a sadistic side to him he revels
in being the brakes on the car
and i think the base it's just going to
be throwing just they're going to want
some bone it's like oh yeah we
eliminated this one person so that's
going to get really ugly really quickly
you see it being quite divisive like
a division increasing not stabilizing or
decreasing and i'll be doing my part i
know you'll be doing my part but i'm
trying to do my part and
like trying to be like to me the
division
is uh shouting over people like elon
musk
uh people who are actually building
stuff and like accomplishing things in
this world in terms of like
elon said he took the red pill
no see you're talking about the play i'm
talking about forget elon
spacex and tesla and uh actually the
good sides of like
some of the things that google is doing
um
like actually building things like
making the world's information
searchable all that kind of stuff
like all the stuff you know the making
actually the world a better
uh place there's a bunch of technologies
that are increasing our quality of life
all this
all that kind of stuff i feel like they
get like not much credit
or in our public discourse because of
the division division is just like
like peop it's clouding our ability to
concentrate on what's awesome about this
world
well you know what would eliminate the
division right secession
yeah see i don't
i don't i ca it's hard for me to
disagree
it's hard for me to disagree because
but at the same time secession um
i'm a romantic at heart divorce breaks
my heart cool
but do you want to live in a country bro
yeah but do you want to live in a
country where joe rogan
is regarded as an example of someone
who's spreading white supremacy
i don't well but see i feel like that's
not
the country we live in that's just the
new york times did it
the cathedral does it on a regular basis
well the cathedral
is okay the the cathedral i guess you
can maybe define the cathedral but
it's like the centralized institutions
that have like a story that they're
trying to sell and so
this is mulbuck's concept but yeah they
basically are set the limits of
permissible discourse and create a
narrative for the population to follow
but to me that's a minority of people
minorities always controlling everything
in any country the vast majority of
masses have no thought yeah but
minorities can be overthrown and
sure the circulation elites yeah the way
the pro no no no
that's the what progress looks like is
ridiculous people take power
yes and then uh they get annoying and
new ridiculous people
that are a little bit better overthrow
the previous no i think people
progress happens despite the people who
are in power not because of them
right and so why is the session
the so is it always about overthrowing
the powerful
is that how progress happens no i think
progress happens despite the powerful
the powerful are going to do what's in
their power
to maintain their power and they're
going to fight innovation because it's a
threat to their control
there's always going to be the new york
times of the world right there's always
going to be those
those people that let them have their
own country
so it's two countries one has joe rogan
the other one has the new york times
that's basically what's happening right
now it's just geographically doesn't
map out very well but culturally yes
but that's just cultural stuff like
there's a layer of public discourse
okay i don't mean like that's what we're
operating under now
but there's actually like progress being
made like roads being built
uh hospitals being run all those kinds
of things like
different innovations that seems like
secession is counter
productive to that right because one
country would have all the roads and the
other would have all the hospitals
that's a great point no it's not that's
not the point i'm trying to make it's
just like
it just feels like the division that
we're experiencing in the space of ideas
could be constructive and productive for
for building better roads and better
hospitals as opposed to like
using that division to separate the
countries they're all going to have to
solve the same problems it feels like
like sure but they can solve them
differently and compete that way
massively a great example yeah we're
seeing that right now different
countries have different mass mandates
and things like this
and uh the competition within the same
structure with
the same founding documents and same
institutions is not effective you think
is
as effective as separating it is
effective but there is a certain point
which i think we have long
past where there is not a consensus a
governing consensus ideologically or
culturally
you